[Music]  I know that love is messy  [Music]  no chance I will be so much better  he's really trying does that mean that I  have to start being nice to him or  something because I can't do it I don't  think not every relationship is simple  is there something you need to tell me I  want to move to New York  [Music]  Daisy I'm gonna propose to Vanessa  that is the one you heard the boss  I'm looking to get a present for my  girlfriend I was hoping that one of  those blue boxes would do the trick let  me show you what we have  what if it is what we think it is I  don't know if I'm ready for this Merry  Christmas  come on  [Music]  he got my ring I got his present you've  got to go get the ring back  together  yeah I'm fine as hell too what are those  oh my God Terry I know something when I  see something and that wasn't nothing  I'm never gonna see him again so  whatever  hello again  [Music]